antidemocrático preocupante indignante
la violencia del domingo en Brasilia por
parte de manifestantes Pro bolsonaro
irrumpiendo en el congreso el Palacio
presidencial y el tribunal supremo y
exigiendo la destitución del presidente
de izquierda Lula da Silva fue condenada
por líderes mundiales que la tacharon
como un ataque a la democracia el
presidente de Estados Unidos
Escandalosa la violencia de Los
partidarios del expresidente brasileño
condeno del asalto a la democracia y al
traspaso Pacífico del poder en Brasil
las instituciones democráticas
brasileñas cuentan con todo nuestro
apoyo el presidente de México Andrés
Manuel López Obrador expresó su apoyo al
presidente Lula Lula no está solo cuenta
con el apoyo de las fuerzas progresistas
de su país de México del continente
americano y del mundo el mandatario
argentino Alberto Fernández condenó por
su parte un intento de golpe de estado
estamos junto al pueblo brasileño para
defender la democracia y no permitir
nunca más el regreso de los fantasmas
golpistas que la derecha promueve el
jefe de estado colombiano Gustavo Petro
cuyo gobierno llamó a una sesión
extraordinaria del Consejo permanente de
la Organización de Estados Americanos
también comentó los hechos en Twitter
toda mi solidaridad a Lula y al pueblo
de Brasil el fascismo decide dar un
golpe las derechas no han podido
mantener el pacto de la no violencia por
último en Europa el presidente del
Consejo europeo
Michelle expresó su absoluta condena del
atentado y su pleno apoyo al presidente
Lula elegido democráticamente por
millones de brasileños